.
Let's solve some quadratic equations by analyzing the factors
Let's assume that I have x ^ 2 + 4x = 21
Perhaps your motivation now is to try to extract x as a common factor
Make the equation equal to 21
This will not lead you to the right solution
You may end up doing it
Nothing is considered satisfactory
What you need to do here is to put the whole squared phrase
On one side of the equation
We will do this and put it on the left side
So let's subtract 21 from both ends of the equation
The left side therefore becomes x ^ 2
+ 4x - 21
And then the right side is limited to 0
And the way you will use them to solve these
Ie, this quadratic equation
We have a quadratic statement equal to 0
The way to solve them is to analyze them into their factors
She says, well, each of these factors can
That equals 0
So how do we analyze them?
Well, we've seen the last show that we had to find
There are two numbers with a total of 21, and the sum of them
Equals 4
This will be a + b = 4
As the result of their multiplication is negative, it must be
Their signals are different
So let's see, the number that will appear
In front of me is 7 and 3
If I have 7-and-3-positive, I'll get it
So let's put positive 7 and 3
If a and b are positive 7 and 3
When I take the hit, I get 21
When I take their sum, get a positive 4
So I can rewrite this equation here
I can rewrite it as (x + 7) (x - 3)
= 0
Now I can say this, see, I have
Two amounts
Their multiplier equals 0
This means that one or both must equal 0
This means that x + 7 = 0
So x
Or that x - 3 = 0
I can subtract 7 from both ends of the equation
I will get x = -7
Here, I can add 3 to both ends of the equation
I will get x = 3
Each of these numbers is considered a solution to this equation
You can try it
If you take the 7 - 7 = 2 = 49
-7 × 4 = -28
This is really worth 21
I will let you try the 3 yourself
In fact, let's do it
3 ^ 2 = 9, + 4 × 3 = 12
9 + 12 = 21
Let's solve more examples
Suppose I have x ^ 2 + 49 = 14x
Again, when you see something like this, make it all
Phrases on one side of the equation to get 0 on
the other side
That is the best way to solve a quadratic equation
So let's ask 14x from both sides
We can write it as x ^ 2 - 14x + 49
= 0
Clearly, the 14x - 14x = 0
This amount - 14x = this amount
Now we just have to think about what the two numbers are when
I take a hit, get 49, and when I take it
Their total, I'll get -14
If first, they must have the same signal as this
Positive number
Both will be negative because
Their total is negative
There is something interesting here
49 is a complete square
Its factors are 1, 7 and 48
Maybe 7 will succeed, or better, maybe
-7 will succeed
It is
-7 × 7 = 49
And -7 + 7 = -14
We have this style here, so we have 2 x
Number, and then we have the number box
This is a full box
This is equal to (x - 7) (x - 7)
= 0
I do not want to forget that
Or we can write as follows (x - 7) ^ 2 = 0
If this is a bipolar and constitutes a whole square
If (x-7) ^ 2 = 0, we take
Square root for both parties
You get x - 7 = 0
I mean, you can say that x - 7 = 0 or x - 7 = 0
But that would be too much
If we get x - 7 = 0
We add 7 for both parties, and we get x = 7
We have one solution here
Let's make one more solution in pink
Suppose we have x ^ 2 - 64 = 0
Now that seems to be something interesting
this is interesting
Maybe a bell will ring in your head
Suggest you solve
There is no x phrase here, but we can believe
That is our x
We can rewrite it as x ^ 2 + 0x - 64
If in this case, we can say, well, what are the two numbers
When I hit them, I get 64, when
Collect them Get 0?
And when I take their hit, I'll get it
A negative number, is not it?
This is a × b
It's a negative number
If this should mean that their signals are different
This should mean that their signals are different
When I collect them, I get 0
This should mean that a + -b = 0, or that
a = b, so we are dealing with the same number
We are dealing with the same number, negative images
For both of them
What could it be?
Well, if we are dealing with the same number they are passive
64 are 8 ^ 2
But it is -64, so maybe we are dealing with
8, and the other we deal with is positive 8
And if we combine them
We will get 0
So it can be (x - 8) (x + 8)
Now you do not always have to go through this
The process you have done here
Maybe you already remember that if I have (a + b) x
(a - b), this equals a ^ 2 - b ^ 2
If you see something like this and fit into this pattern, that is a ^ 2
- b ^ 2, you can say directly, that this
Equals (a + b) --a = x and b = 8 - × (a - b)
Let us solve more general examples, and I will not tell you
What kind
Let me change colors
This has become an intrigue
Let's assume that we have x ^ 2 - 24x
+ 144 = 0
Well, 144 is clearly 12 ^ 2
This is clearly worth 2 × 12
Or that this is a -12 ^ 2
If this is 12 x 12
This is -12 + -12
If this statement can be rewritten as (x - 12) x
(x - 12), or (x - 12) ^ 2
This will be equal to 0
This is equal to 0 when x-12 = 0
You can say that none of these are equal to 0, but they are
Equal anyway
Add 12 to the ends of that equation and get x
= 12
I realized that, from this top question, which I analyzed
But I have not really solved this equation
If this should equal 0
Let's take a step back into this equation
The only way that makes this equal to 0 is
If x - 8 = 0 or x +
8 = 0
If we add 8 to both ends
We get x = 8
We subtract 8 from both parties
We get x = -8
Let us solve another example
So realize the idea completely
Suppose we have 4x ^ 2 - 25 = 0
Maybe you've seen this pattern already
This is a ^ 2
This is b ^ 2
Our pattern is a ^ 2 - b ^ 2
Where a in this case is equal to x, right?
This is 2x ^ 2
And b = 5
If you have -b ^ 2, this is
Will equal (a + b) (a - b)
In this case, this means that 4x ^ 2-25
It will be (2x + 5) (2x - 5)
Of course, this equals 0
This equals 0 only if it is 2x + 5 =
0 or 2x - 5 = 0
And then we can solve each one of these
We subtract 5 from both parties
We get 2x = -5
Divide both sides on 2
You can get one solution which is -5/2
Here, add 5 for both parties
And you get 2x = 5
Divide both sides on 2
We get x = 5/2
If both of them achieve that equation
.